The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
Well, we had an election
since I saw you last.
I hope you're happy
about the results.
I'm very happy.
Except one thing.
There was a senator
who was in 18.085.
And he lost his seat.
So we don't have a senator
from 18.085 any more.
It was Senator Sununu,
from New Hampshire.
So he took 18.085.
Actually, it was a
funny experience.
So, some years ago I
had to go to Washington
to testify before a
committee about increasing
the funding for mathematics.
So I was nervous, of
course, trying to remember
what I'm going to say.
More money is the
main point, but you
have to say it more
delicately than that.
And so I got in, a lot of
people were taking turns,
you only get five
minutes to do it.
And so I went and sat
down, waited for my turn.
And here on the committee was
my student, Senator Sununu.
Well at that time, I think,
Representative Sununu.
So that was nice.
He's a nice guy.
Actually, the lobbyist who
kind of guided me there,
and found the room for me and
sort of told me what to do,
said I hope you gave him an
A. And the truth is I didn't.
So I guess you guys
should all get As, just
to be on the safe side.
Or let me know if you're going
to be in the Senate anyway.
So there you go.
Anyway.
So alright.
But he wasn't great in 18.085.
OK, so you know
what, this evening--
I just called the
schedules office
to confirm that it is
tonight, in 54-100.
It's not a long, difficult
exam so see you at 7:30,
or see you earlier at 4:00
for a review of everything
that you want to ask about.
So I won't try to do an
exam review this morning;
we've got lots to do and
we're into November already.
So I want to finish the
discussion of the fast Poisson
solver.
Because it's just a neat
idea which is so simple.
Anytime you have a
nice square grid.
I guess the message
is, anytime you
have a nice square
or rectangular grid,
you should be thinking, use the
fast Fourier transform somehow.
And here it turns out
that the eigenvectors
are, for this problem,
this K2D, so we're
getting this matrix K2D.
Which is of size N squared by
N squared, so a large matrix.
But its eigenvectors
will be, well,
actually they'll
be sine functions
for the K2D, the fixed-fixed.
And they would be cosine
functions for the B2D,
free-free.
And the point is the
fast Fourier transform
does all those fast.
I mean, the fast
Fourier transform
is set up for the
complex exponentials
as we'll see in a
couple of weeks.
That's the most
important algorithm
I could tell you about.
After maybe Gaussian
elimination, I don't know.
But my point here is that if
you can do complex exponentials
fast, you can do sines fast,
you can do cosines fast,
and the result will be
that instead of-- I did
an operation count
when I did elimination
in the order one, two,
three, four, five, six,
ordered by along each row.
That gave us a matrix that
I want to look at again,
this K2D matrix.
If I did elimination
as it stands,
I think the count was N^4.
I think the count
was, size N squared,
I had N squared columns to work
on and I think each column took
N squared steps,
so I was up to N^4.
And that's manageable.
2-D problems, you really
can use backslash.
But for this particular
problem, using the FFT way,
it comes down to N squared
log N. So that's way better.
Way better.
Big saving.
In 1-D, you don't see a saving.
But in 2-D it's a big saving,
and in 3-D an enormous saving.
So a lot of people would like
to try to use the FFT also
when the region isn't a square.
You can imagine all the
thinking that goes into this.
But we'll focus on the
one where it's a square.
Oh, one thing more to add.
I spoke about
reordering the unknowns.
But you probably were wondering,
OK, what's that about because I
only just referred to it.
Let me suggest an
ordering and you
can tell me what
the matrix K2D will
look like in this ordering.
I'll call it the
red-black ordering.
I guess with the
election just behind us
I could call it the
red-blue ordering.
OK, red-blue ordering, OK.
So the ordering, instead of
ordering it by-- Let me draw
this again, I'll put in a
couple more, make N=4 here,
so now I've got 16,
N squared is now 16.
So here's the idea.
The red-blue ordering
is like a checkerboard.
The checkerboard ordering,
you could think of.
This will be one, this'll
be two, this'll be three,
this'll be four, five,
six, seven, eight.
So I've numbered
from one to eight.
And now 9 to 16 will
be the other guys.
These will be 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
So suppose I do that,
what K2D look like?
Maybe you could,
it's a neat example.
It gives us one more chance
to look at this matrix.
So K2D is always going to
have fours on the diagonal.
So I have 16 fours.
Whatever order I take, the
equation at a typical point,
like say this one, that's
point number one, two.
That's point number three,
at a point number three
I have my five point molecule
with a four in the middle.
So it'd be a four in
this, on that position.
And then I have the four guys
around it, the minus ones,
and where will they
appear in the matrix?
With this ordering.
So you get to see the
point of an ordering.
So this was point one,
point two, point three,
I'm focusing on point three.
It's got a four on the diagonal
and then it's got a minus one,
a minus one, a minus
one, a minus one,
where do they appear?
Well, all those
guys are what color?
They're all color blue.
Right?
All the neighbors
are colored blue.
So I won't get to
them until I've
gone through the
red, the eight reds,
and then I come back to nine.
Whatever, 11, 12, 13.
The point is they'll
all be over here.
So this is like, you see
that the only nodes that
are next to a red
node are all blue.
And the only nodes next
to a blue node are red.
So this is filled in
a little bit, that's
where I've sort of like
four diagonals of minus ones
or something.
But there you go.
That gives you an idea of what
a different ordering could be.
And you see what will
happen now with elimination?
Elimination is completed
already on this stuff.
So all the-- With
elimination you
want to push the
non-zeroes way to the end.
That's sort of like
the central idea is,
it's kind of a greedy approach.
Greedy algorithm.
Use up zeroes while
the sun's shining.
And then near the end,
where the problem is,
elimination's reduced it
to a much smaller problem,
then you've got some work to do.
So that's what
would happen here.
By the way there's a
movie, on the 18.086 page.
I hope some of you guys
will consider taking 18.086.
It's a smaller class,
people do projects
like creating this
elimination movie.
So that would be
math.mit.edu/18.086,
and with the movie-- has a
movie of different orderings.
That to try to figure out what's
the absolute best ordering
with the absolute
least fill-in is,
that's one of these NP-hard
combinatorial problems.
But to get an ordering that's
much better than by rows
is not only doable
but should be done.
OK, so that's the
ordering for elimination.
As this is for elimination.
OK.
So that's a whole
world of its own.
Ordering the thing for
Gaussian elimination.
My focus in this section 3.5, so
this is Section 3.5 of the book
and then this is Section
3.6, which is our major one.
That's our big deal.
But my focus in
3.5 is first to try
to see what the 2-D matrix is.
I mean, a big part
of this course,
I think, a big part of what I
can do for you, is to, like,
get comfortable with matrices.
Sort of see what do you look
at when you see a matrix?
What's its shape?
What are its properties?
And so this K2D is our first
example of a 2-D matrix,
and it's highly structured.
The point is we'll
have K2D matrices out
of finite elements.
But the finite elements might
be, well, they could be those.
This could be a finite
element picture.
And then the finite element
matrix on such a regular mesh
would be quite structured too.
But if I cut them
all up into triangles
and I have a curved
region and everything,
an unstructured mesh, then I'll
still have the good properties,
this will still be
symmetric positive definite,
all the good stuff.
But the FFT won't come in.
OK, so now I want to take a look
again at this K2D matrix, OK?
So one way to describe
the K2D matrix
is the way I did last
time, to kind of write down
the typical row, typical
row in the middle.
It's got a four on the
diagonal and four minus ones.
And here we've re-ordered it so
the four minus ones came off.
Came much later.
But either way, that's
what the matrix looks like.
Let me go back to this ordering.
And let's get 2-D, another
better, clearer look at K2D.
I want to construct K2D
from K. Which is this K1D.
I don't use that
name, but here it is.
Let me just show it to you.
OK, so let me take
the matrix that
does the second differences
in the x direction.
This'll be an N squared
by N squared matrix.
And it'll take second
differences on every row.
Let me just write
in what it'll be.
It'll be K, it'll
be a block matrix.
K, K, n blocks.
Each n by n.
You see that that will be
the second difference matrix?
K takes the second
differences along a row.
This K will take the second x
differences along the next row.
Row by row, simple.
So this is the u_xx part.
Now what will the u_yy,
the second y derivative--
That gives second differences
up the columns, right?
So can I see what
that matrix will
look like, second
differences up the columns?
Well, I think it
will look like this.
It will have twos
on the diagonal.
2I, 2I, 2I, this is
second differences, right?
Down to 2I.
And next to it will be a minus
the identity-- Let me write it,
and you see if you
think it looks good.
So minus the identity.
It's like a blown up K. Somehow.
Right?
I have, do you see, it's every
row has got a two and two minus
ones.
That's from the minus one
the two and the minus one
in the vertical
second difference.
But you see how the count, you
see how the numbering changed
it from here?
Here the neighbors were
right next to each other,
because we're ordering by rows.
Here I have to wait a whole
N to get the guy above.
And I'm also N away
from the guy below.
So this is the two, minus
one, minus one centered there,
above and below.
Do you see that?
If you think about
it a little it's
not sort of difficult to see.
And I guess the thing
I want also to do,
is to tell you that there's
a neat little MATLAB command,
or neat math idea really, and
they just made a MATLAB command
out of it, that produces this
matrix and this one out of K.
Can I tell you what this is?
It's something you don't see in
typical linear algebra courses.
So I'm constructing
K2D from K1D by,
this is called a
Kronecker product.
It's named after a
guy, some dead German.
Or sometimes called
tensor product.
The point is, this is
always the simplest
thing to do in two dimensions
or three dimensions, or so on.
Is like product of
1-D things, like
copy the 1-D idea both ways.
That's all this thing is doing.
Copying the one idea
in the x direction
and in the y direction.
So the MATLAB command,
I've got two pieces here.
For this first piece it's
kron, named after Kronecker,
of-- Now, let's see.
I'm going to put
two N by N matrices,
and Kronecker product is going
to be a matrix, a giant matrix,
of size N squared.
Like these.
OK, so I want to write
the right thing in there.
I think the right thing
is the identity and K. OK,
and so I have to explain what
this tensor product, Kronecker
product, is.
And this guy happens to be
also a Kronecker product.
But it's K and I. So I'm
just like mentioning here.
That because if you have 2-D
problems and 3-D problems
and they're on a nice square
grid so you can like just
take products of things, this
is what you want to know about.
OK.
So what is this
Kronecker product?
Kronecker product says
take the first matrix,
I. It's N by N. Just N by
N, that's the identity.
And now take this K and multiply
every one of those numbers,
these are all numbers, let
me put more numbers in,
so I've got 16 numbers.
This is going to work
for this mesh that has
four guys in each direction.
And four directions.
Four levels.
So I is four by four,
and K is four by four
and now, each number here
gets multiplied by K. So
because of all those zeroes
I get just K, K, K, K. Which
is exactly what I wanted.
So that Kronecker product
just-- In one step
you've created an N
squared by N squared matrix
that you really would not want
to type in entry by entry.
That would be a horrible idea.
OK, and if I follow the
same principle here,
I'll take the
Kronecker product here,
as I start with a matrix
K, so I start with two,
minus one, minus one; two, minus
one, minus one; two, minus one,
minus one; two.
That's my K, and now
what's the Kronecker idea?
Each of those numbers gets
multiplied by this matrix.
So that two becomes 2I, minus
one becomes minus I, minus one
becomes minus I, it all clicks.
And it's producing exactly the
u_yy part, the second part.
So that's the good construction,
just to tell you about.
And the beauty is, this
is just like cooked up,
set up for separation
of variables.
If I want to know
the eigenvalues
and the eigenvectors
of this thing,
I start by knowing the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of K. Can you remind
me what those are?
We should remember them.
So, anybody remember
eigenvectors of K?
Well, this is going
back to Section 1.5,
way early in the semester.
And there's a lot
of writing involved
and I probably didn't do it all.
But let me remind
you of the idea.
We guessed those eigenvectors.
And how did we guess them?
We guessed them by comparing
this difference equation
to the differential equation.
So we're in 1-D now,
I'm just reminding you
of what we did a long time ago.
OK, so what did we do?
I want to know the
eigenvectors of these guys.
So I better know the
eigenvectors of the 1-D one
first.
OK, so what did we do in 1-D?
We found the eigenvectors
of K by looking first
at the differential equation
-u''=lambda*u with--
And remember we're talking
about the fixed-fixed here.
And anybody remember
the eigenvectors
of this guy, eigenfunctions I
guess I should say for those?
So sines and cosines
look good here, right?
Because you take their
second derivative,
it brings down the constant.
And then do I want
sines or cosines?
Looking at the
boundary conditions,
that's going to
tell me everything.
I want sines, cosines are wiped
out by this first condition
that u(0) should be zero.
And then the sine has to
come back to zero at one,
so the eigenfunctions were u
equals the sine of something,
I think.
I want a multiple of
pi, right? pi*k*x.
I think that would be right.
Because at x=1, that's
come back to zero.
And the eigenvalue lambda,
if I just plug that in, two
derivatives bring
down pi*k twice.
And with a minus, and
that cancels that minus.
So the eigenvalues were
pi squared k squared.
And that's the
beautiful construction
for differential equations.
And these eigenfunctions
are a complete set,
it's all wonderful.
So that's a model problem of
what classical applied math
does for Bessel's equation,
Legendre's equation,
a whole long list of things.
Now, note all those
equations that I just
mentioned would have
finite difference analogs.
But to my knowledge, it's only
this one, this simplest, best
one of all, we could call
it the Fourier equation
if we needed a name for it.
I just thought of that.
That sounds good to me.
Fourier equation.
OK.
So what's great
about this one is
that the eigenvectors
in the matrix case
are just found by
sampling these functions.
You're right on the dot if you
just sample these functions.
So, for K, the eigenvectors,
what do I call eigenvectors?
Maybe y's, I think I
sometimes call them y.
So a typical eigenvector
y would be a sine vector.
I'm sampling it at, let's see,
can I use h for this step size?
So h is 1/(n+1).
As we saw in the
past. h is 1/(n+1).
So a typical eigenvector would
sample this thing at h, 2h, 2h,
2h, sin(2*pi*k*h), and
so on, dot dot dot dot.
And that would be
an eigenvector.
That would be the eigenvector
number k, actually.
And do you see that that sort
of eigenvector is well set up.
It's going to work because
it ends, where does it end?
Who's the last person, the last
component of this eigenvector?
It's sin(N*pi*k*h).
Sorry about all the symbols, but
compared to most eigenvectors
this is, like, the greatest.
OK, now why do I like that?
Because the pattern, what
would be the next one
if there was an N plus first?
If there was an N plus first
component, what would it be?
What would be the
sine of (N+1)*pi*k*h?
That's the golden question.
What would be, I'm trying to say
that these have a nice pattern
because the guy that's-- the
next person here would be
sin((N+1)*pi*k*h),
which is what?
So N+1 is in there.
And h is in there, so what
do I get from those guys?
The (N+1)h is just one, right?
(N+1)h carries me all the way
to the end.
That's a guy that's out,
it's not in our matrix
because that's the part,
that's a known one, that's
a zero in a fixed
boundary condition.
So like, the next guy would
be sine (N+1)h, that's one.
sin(pi*k).
And what is sin(pi*k)?
The sine of pi*k is always?
Zero.
So we're getting it
right, like, the guy that
got knocked off following
this pattern will be zero.
And what about the guy that
was knocked off of that end?
If this was sin(2pi*k*h),
and sin(pi*k*h),
this would be sin(0pi*k*h),
which would be?
Also zero, sin(0).
So, anyway you could check just
by, it takes a little patience
with trig identities, if I
multiply K by that vector,
the pattern keeps going, the
two minus one, minus one,
you know at a typical point
I'm going to have two of these,
minus one of these,
minus one of these.
And it'll look good.
And when I get to the end I'll
have two minus one of these.
The pattern will still
hold, because the minus one
of these I can say is there.
But it is a zero, so it's OK.
And similarly here.
Anyway, the pattern's good
and the eigenvalue is?
Something.
OK, it has some formula.
It's not going to
be exactly this guy.
Because we're taking
differences of sines
and not derivatives of sines.
So it has some formula.
Tell me what you would
know about lambda.
I'm not going to ask
you for the formula,
I'm going to write it down.
Tell me, before I write it
down, or I'll write it down
and then you can tell me.
I have two on the
diagonal, so that's just
going to give me a two.
And then the guy on the left
and the guy on the right, two,
two with minus ones
I think gives two,
I think it turns out to
be a cosine of k-- a k has
to be in there, a pi has
to be in there, and h.
I think that'll be it.
I think that's the eigenvalue.
That's the k-th eigenvalue
to go with this eigenvector.
What do you notice about
two minus two times
the cosine of something?
What is it?
Positive, negative,
zero, what's up?
Two minus to times
a cosine is always?
Positive.
What does that tell us about
K that we already knew?
It's positive definite, right?
All eigenvalues, here we
actually know what they all
are, they're all positive.
I'm never going
to get zero here.
These k*pi*h's are not hitting
the ones where the cosine is
one and, of course,
you can imagine.
So I started this
sentence and realized
I should add another sentence.
These are all positive.
We expected that.
We knew that K was a
positive definite matrix.
All its eigenvalues
are positive,
and now we actually
know what they are.
And if I had the matrix B
instead, for a free-free one?
Then this formula would
change a little bit.
And what would be different
about B, the free-free matrix?
Its eigenvectors would
be maybe at half angles
or some darned thing happens.
And so we get something
slightly different here.
Maybe h is 1/n for
that, I've forgotten.
And what's the deal
with the free-free K?
One of the eigenvalues is zero.
The free-free is the positive
semi-definite example.
OK, that was like a quick
review of stuff we did earlier.
And so I'm coming back to
that early point in the book,
because of this great fact
that my eigenvectors are sines.
So the point is, my
eigenvectors being
sines, that just lights
up a light saying
use the fast Fourier transform.
You've got a matrix
full of sine vectors.
Your eigenvector matrix
is a sine transform.
It's golden, so use it.
So I'll just remember then
how, recall that-- So what are
the eigenvectors in 2-D?
First of all, so
let's go to 2-D.
Let me do the
continuous one first.
Yeah, -u_xx-u_yy=lambda*u.
The eigenvalue problem for
Laplace's equation now in 2-D,
and again I'm going to
make it on the square.
The unit square.
And I'm going to have
zero boundary conditions.
Fixed-fixed.
Anybody want to propose an
eigenfunction for the 2-D
problem?
So the 2-D one, the
whole idea is hey,
this square is like a
product of intervals somehow.
We know the answer
in each direction.
What do you figure, what would
be a good eigenfunction u(x,y)?
Or eigenfunction, yeah, u(x,y).
For this problem?
What do you think?
This is like the-- The older
courses on applied math
did this until you
were blue in the face.
Because there wasn't
finite elements and good
stuff at that time.
It was exact formulas.
You wondered about
exact eigenfunctions
and for this problem
variables separate.
And you get u(x) is the
product of sine, of this guy,
sin(pi*k*x), times
the sine of pi*l*y.
Well, once you have the idea
that it might look like that,
you just plug it in to
see, does it really work?
And what's the eigenvalue?
So I claim that that's a
good eigenfunction function
and I need, it's got
two indices, k and l,
two frequencies.
It's got an x frequency
and a y frequency.
So I need double index. k and l
will go, yeah, all the way out
to infinity in the
continuous problem.
And what's the eigenvector?
Can you plug this guy in?
What happens when
you plug that in?
Take the second x
derivative, what happens?
A constant comes out
and what's the constant?
pi squared k squared.
Then plug it into that term.
A constant comes out again.
What's that constant?
pi squared l squared.
They come out with
a minus and then
you already built in the minus,
so that they've made it a plus.
So the lambda_kl is just
pi squared k squared,
plus pi squared l squared.
You see how it's going?
If we knew it in 1-D
now we get it in 2-D,
practically for free.
Just the idea of doing this.
OK, and now I'm going to do
it for finite differences.
So now I have K2D and I want to
ask you about its eigenvectors,
and what do you think they are?
Well, of course,
they're just like those.
They're just, the eigenvectors,
shall I call them z_kl?
So these will be
the eigenvectors.
The eigenvectors z_kl will
be, their components-- I
don't even know the
best way to write them.
The trouble is this matrix
is of size N squared.
Its eigenvectors have
got N squared components,
and what are they?
Just you could tell me in words.
What do you figure
are going to be
the components of the
eigenvectors in K2D
when you know them in 1-D?
Products, of course.
This construction, however I
write it, is just like this.
z_kl, a typical component,
typical components--
So the components of the
eigenvectors are products
of these guys, like sin(k*pi*h),
something like that.
I've got indices that I
don't want to get into.
Just damn it, I'll
just put that.
Sine here or something, right.
We could try to sort
out the indices,
the truth is a kron
operation does it for us.
So all I'm saying is we've
got an eigenvector with N
components in the x direction.
We've got another one with
index l, N components in the y
direction.
Multiply these N guys by these
N guys, you get N squared guys.
Whatever order
you write them in.
And that's the eigenvector.
And then the eigenvalue is,
so the eigenvalue will be,
well what do we got?
We have a second x difference,
so it will be a 2-2cos(k*pi*h).
From the xx term.
And it'll plus the other term
will be a 2-2cos(l*pi*h).
That's cool, yeah.
I didn't get into writing the
details of the eigenvector,
that's a mess.
This is not a mess.
This is nice.
What do I see again?
I see four coming
from the diagonal.
I see two minus ones
coming from left and right.
coming from up and below.
And do I see a positive number?
You bet.
Right, this is positive,
this is positive.
Sum is positive.
The sum of two positive definite
matrices is positive definite.
I know everything about K.
And the fast Fourier transform
makes all those
calculations possible.
So maybe I, just to
conclude this subject,
would be to remind
you, how do you
use the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
in solving the equation?
I guess I'd better
put that on a board.
But this is what
we did last time.
So the final step would be
how do I solve (K2D)U=F?
You remember, what
were the three steps?
I do really want you to
learn those three steps.
It's the way eigenvectors
and eigenvalues are used.
It's the whole point
of finding them.
The whole point of finding them
is to split this problem into N
squared little 1-D problems,
where each eigenvector is just
doing its own thing.
So what do you do?
You write F as a combination,
with some coefficients c_kl,
of the eigenvectors y_kl.
So these are vectors.
Put an arrow over them
just to emphasize.
Those are vectors.
Then what's the answer,
let's skip the middle step
which was so easy.
Tell me the answer.
Supposed the right-hand side is
a combination of eigenvectors.
Then the left-hand
side, the answer,
is also a combination
of eigenvectors.
And just tell me, what
are the coefficients
in that combination?
This is like the whole idea
is on two simple lines here.
The coefficient there is?
What do I have? c_kl,
does that come in?
Yes, because c_kl tells me
how much of this eigenvector
is here.
But now, what else
comes in? lambda_kl,
and what do I do with that?
Divide by it, because when I
multiply that'll multiply by it
and bring back F.
So there you go.
That's the-- This U is
a vector, of course.
These are all vectors.
2-D, we'll give them
an arrow, just as
a reminder that these are
vectors with N squared
components.
They're giant
vectors, but the point
is this y_kl, its N squared
components are just products,
as we saw here, of
the 1-D problem.
So the fast Fourier transform,
the 2-D fast Fourier transform
just takes off.
Takes off and gives you
this fantastic speed.
So that's absolutely the right
way to solve the problem.
And everybody sees that picture?
Don't forget that picture.
That's like a nice
part of this subject,
is to get-- It's
formulas and not code.
But it's easily
turned into code.
Because the FFT and the sine
transform are all coded.
Actually, Professor Johnson
in the Math Department,
he created the best
FFT code there is.
Do you know that?
I'll just mention.
His code is called FFTW, Fastest
Fourier Transform in the West,
and the point is it's set up to
be fast on whatever computer,
whatever architecture
you're using.
It figures out what that is.
And optimizes the code for that.
And gives you the answer.
OK.
That's Part 2 complete,
of Section 3.5.
I guess I'm hoping after
we get through the quiz,
the next natural step would
be some MATLAB, right?
We really should have some
MATLAB case of doing this.
I haven't thought
of it, but I'll try.
And some MATLAB for
finite elements.
And there's a lot of
finite element code
on the course page,
ready to download.
But now we have
to understand it.
Are you ready to tackle,
so in ten minutes
we can get the central idea
of finite elements in 2-D,
and then after the quiz, when
our minds are clear again,
we'll do it properly Friday.
This is asking you a
lot, but can I do it?
Can I go to finite
elements in 2-D?
OK.
Oh, I have a choice.
Big, big choice.
I could use triangles, or quads.
That picture, this picture would
naturally set up for quads.
Let me start with triangles.
So I have some region with
lots of triangles here.
Got to have some
interior points,
or I'm not going to
have any unknowns.
Gosh, that's a big mesh
with very little unknown.
Let me put in another few here.
Have I got enough?
Oops, that's not a triangle.
How's that?
Is that now a triangulation?
So that's an unstructured
triangular mesh.
Its quality is not too bad.
The angles, some angles are
small but not very small.
And they're not near-- That
angle's getting a little big
too, it's getting toward
a 180 degrees which
you have to stay away from.
If it was a 180, the
triangle would squash in.
So it's a bit
squashed, that one.
This one's a little
long and narrow.
But not bad.
And you need a mesh generator
to generate a mesh like this.
And I had a thesis student
just a few years ago
who wrote a nice mesh
generator in MATLAB.
So we get a mesh.
OK.
Now, do you remember
the finite element idea?
Well, first you have
to use the weak form.
Let's save the weak form
for first thing Friday.
The weak form of Laplace.
I need the weak form
of Laplace's equation.
I'll just tell you what it is.
We all have double integrals.
Oh, Poisson.
I'm making it Poisson.
I want a right-hand side.
Double integral,
this will be du/dx.
d test function/dx.
And now what's
changed in 2-D, I'll
also have a du/dy dv/dy, dxdy.
That's what I'll get.
And on the right-hand
side I'll just
have f, the load,
times the test. dxdy.
Yeah I guess, I have to write
that down because that's
our starting point.
Do you remember the situation,
and of course that's
on the exam this evening,
is remembering about
the weak form in
1-D. So in 2-D I
expect to see x's and y's,
my functions are functions
of x and y.
I have my, this is my solution.
The v's are all
possible test functions,
and this hold for every--
This is like the virtual work.
You could call it the equation
of virtual work, if your
were a little old-fashioned.
Those v's are virtual
displacements,
they're test functions.
That's what it looks like.
I'll come back to that
at the start of Friday.
What's the finite element idea?
Just as in 1-D, the
finite element idea
is choose some trial
functions, right?
Choose some trial functions.
And our approximate guy is
going to be some combination
of these trial functions.
Some coefficient U_1
times the first trial
function plus so on, plus U_n
times the n-th trial function.
So this will be our--
And these will also
be our test functions again.
These will also be, the
phis are also the V's.
I'll get an equation.
By using n tests, by
using the weak form
n times for these n functions.
And so each equation comes--
V is one of the phis,
U is this combination of phis.
Plug it in.
You get an equation.
What do I got to do
in three minutes, is
speak about the most
important point.
The phis.
Choosing the phis
is what matters.
That's what made
finite elements win.
The fact that I choose nice
simple functions, which
are polynomials, little easy
polynomials on each element,
on each triangle.
And the ones I'm going
to speak about today
are the linear ones.
They're like hat
functions, right?
But now we're in 2-D.
They're going to be pyramids.
So if I take, this is
unknown number one.
Unknown number one, it's
got its hat function.
Pyramid function, sorry.
Pyramid function.
So its pyramid function
is a one there, right?
The pyramid, top of the
pyramid is over that point.
And it goes down to zero so
it's zero at all these points.
Well, at all the other points.
That's the one beauty
of finite elements,
is that then this U, this
coefficient U_1 that we
compute, will actually be our
approximation at this point.
Because all the others
are zero at that point.
So can you just,
this is all you have
to do in the last 60 seconds
is visualize this function.
Do you see it?
Maybe tent would be
better than pyramid?
Either one.
What's the base of the pyramid?
The base of the
pyramid, I'm thinking
of the surface as a way to
visualize this function.
It's a function that's one here,
it goes down to zero linearly.
So these are linear
triangular elements.
What's the base of the pyramid?
Just this, right?
That's the base.
Because over in these
other triangles,
nothing ever got off zero.
Nothing got off the ground.
It's zero, zero,
zero at all three.
If I know it at all three
corners, I know it everywhere.
For linear functions, it's
just a piece of flat roof.
Piece of flat roof.
So I have, how many pieces
have I got around this point?
Oh, where is the point?
I guess I've got one, two,
three, four, five, six, is it?
It's a six, it's a pyramid with
six sloping faces sloping down
to zero along the sides, right?
So it's like a six-sided
teepee, six-sided tent.
And here are the, the
rods that hold the tent up
would be these six things.
And then the six sides
would be six flat pieces.
If you would see what I've tried
to draw there, that's phi_1.
And you can imagine
that when I've got that,
I can take the x derivative
and the y derivative.
What will I know about the x
derivative and the y derivative
in a typical triangle?
If my function is in a typical
triangle, say in this triangle,
my function looks like a+bx+cy.
a+bx-- it's flat.
It's linear.
And these three numbers, a
and b, are decided by the fact
that the function should be
one there, zero there, and zero
there.
Three facts about
the function, three
coefficients to
match those facts.
And what's the deal
on the x derivative?
It's just b.
It's a constant.
The y derivative is
just c, a constant.
So the integrals are easy and
the the whole finite element
system just goes smoothly.
So then what the finite
element system has to do,
and we'll talk
about it Friday, is
gotta keep track of which
triangles go to which nodes.
How do you assemble, where
do these pieces go in?
But every finite-- every element
matrix is going to be simple.
OK.